what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder where we talk all
things Marvel and MCU I'm your host
Warren Thompson and episode 5 of
She-Hulk just came out and the episode
was all right but by far the most
exciting thing to happen in She-Hulk so
far is the final scene of this episode
episode 5 and the credits specifically
the cartoon sketches that are shown in
the credits after each episode this one
in particular has a very very
interesting scene now of course before
we really dive into this if you have not
seen She-Hulk episode 5 and you care
about spoilers now's your chance to
click away but if you've seen it and you
simply don't care let's dive into it now
right away obviously let's talk about
the ending Daredevil just as I predicted
Daredevil was not in this episode he
will be in episode 6 but he was teased
at the very end we are introduced to
Luke a person who designs the outfits
for superheroes and as he says himself
his stuff is impeccable and he designs
top grade combat gear for the
superheroes as She-Hulk goes into her
dressing room as he gives her her
clothing he walks out sees a box grabs
it and says hello this shouldn't be left
out in the open Tinsley does client
confidentiality mean nothing to you he
then puts the box down and then we see
that it's the helmet for Daredevil now
notice that it is completely yellow now
we knew this was going to happen we knew
that it was not going to be the same
suit from the Netflix Daredevil series
but it was indeed going to be yellow
like his yellow comic suit now this
doesn't really come as a big shock we've
seen Daredevil literally in the trailers
for She-Hulk and not only have we seen
Daredevil but we've also seen Matt
Murdock as well so the ending for
episode 5 of She-Hulk teases Daredevil
is coming in the next episode which
answers our question when is he going to
be coming we've waited five episodes but
we have our answer now let's move on to
the credits like I mentioned this one
was actually really really cool and
actually one of the best parts of
She-Hulk so far if you cut to the time
stamp of 25 minutes and 32 seconds
you'll see something extremely cool in
this episode we learned that pug is a
shoe collector and he asked Nikki to go
with him to get a new pair of Iron Man 3
so he could get two pairs one to wear
and of course one to collect we didn't
see this scene in the episode but in the
credits while they're rolling we do get
the sketch now in pugs hands are the
Iron Man 3s but if you take a look at
the background there are a ton of
different shoes for a ton of different
superheroes and a lot of X-Men so of
course what we're gonna do right now is
break it all down which shoes belong to
which different character and big shout
out to one my live stream last night and
two Greg John and Coy over at the real
rejects we all work together to figure
these shoes out now we've discovered who
the vast majority of them are but there
are a few that we can't be 100 percent
sure about right now that I would love
your input for in the comments Down
Below in the very top right it looks
like we have shoes for America Chavez
right below her we can obviously see
Deadpool now we know Deadpool is coming
to the MCU hopefully in phase six
hopefully really soon so it would make
sense that he was there also we are
going to dive into are all of these
superheroes for the shoes actually in
the MCU after we go over each shoe now
the shoe below Deadpool kind of looks
like it could be the Silver Surfer this
is one that we're not 100 sure on but it
does indeed look like it could be the
Silver Surfers now below those are Thor
oh G Thor and these are great I would
totally buy them now moving over to the
left the shoes above Nikki's head seem
to be cables the pouches are kind of a
giveaway there some people have also
made the case for storm from the
Animated Series but I'm thinking more
cable now to the left of that shoe we
have a little bit of a debate here on my
screen the shoe looks like it's yellow
and blue however when I talked to Greg
Coy and John they said that it looks
like it is yellow and purple which could
be Thanos however if it is yellow and
blue this could be Wolverine those are
his colors now below that shoe it is
very obvious what shoe this is It's a
shoe for the thing the thing of the
Fantastic Four Ben Grimm now what's
really interesting about this is there
was a rumor going around before She-Hulk
even started that the thing was going to
be introduced in the She-Hulk series
that he would appear in one episode and
this shoe kind of makes us think that
this rumor very well could happen of
course it's not confirmed and that is
just a rumor and who knows what these
shoes can mean but this is 100 a shoe
for the thing and this gets even more
exciting below the thing shoe we can see
Vision now Vision was obviously in one
division no surprise there but below
that shoe is a shoe for Cyclops and it
looks awesome I would totally buy and
wear this shoe so we have another X-Men
here another shoe for for another X-Men
cyclops and what's really interesting
about this is that there was concept art
for Miss Marvel that showed somebody in
Cosplay at Avengers con as Cyclops
wearing his Cyclops X-men uniform so
does that piece of concept art combined
with this sketch in She-Hulk confirmed
that Cyclops and the X-Men do exist in
the MCU I'm thinking yes but we'll talk
about that more after we go over the
shoes and we have a ton of shoes left to
break down but first a big thank you to
Mint mobile for sponsoring this video
most people know about mint mobile
because of Ryan Reynolds but most people
don't know about mint Mobile's amazing
quality now I live in the mountains and
service isn't too good however mint
mobile sent me a free plan and I get
better service with their plan than I do
with my other provider but what's crazy
is their plan is so much cheaper mint
mobile offers Wireless for just 15 bucks
a month they give you the best rate
whether you're buying for one or a
family and at mint mobile families start
at only two lines all plans come with
unlimited talk and text plus high-speed
data delivered on the nation's largest
5G Network plus mint Mobile's Modern
Family Plan lets you mix and match data
plans so everyone gets the amount of
data that's right for them and you can
use your own phone and keep your same
number and contacts so to get your new
Wireless plan for just 15 bucks a month
including the Modern Family Plan go to
mintmobile.com Cosmic that's
mintmobile.com Cosmic cut your wireless
build down to 15 bucks a month at
mintmobile.com Cosmic now below
cyclops's shoes are black panther I
think this one is fairly obvious and
Below black panther is kind of hard to
make out we just see a white shoe with a
little bit of green on it it could be a
reference to Doctor Doom but it's really
really hard to make out it also could be
king but like I said it's hard to make
out now moving over to the next row the
one to the left of it at the very top we
see purple and pink shoes that have a
big h on them which seem to be clearly
Hawkeye his comic colors are purple and
it's a big H that seems fairly obvious
however the ones below them are a bit
tricky this could be Dr Doom
representing the front of them the two
golden circles holding up his cape could
be those two circles that we see there
on the shoe or this could be Frogman and
those two golden circles could be the
eyes of Frogman now Frogman is supposed
to appear in the She-Hulk Series so I'm
inclined to say Frogman however I'm
pretty sure Dr Doom is coming to the MCU
pretty soon as well so it could be
either or let me know what you think in
the comments now below those shoes are
the shoes for Bishop it's very clear
because it has that Big M and Bishop has
the M over his eyes also those are his
colors so we have another X-Men here now
below him is the Green Goblin we see the
Big Pumpkin on top and those are the
Green Goblin colors below is fairly
obvious Captain Marvel below that is
Spider-Man some people in my live stream
were saying maybe the Scarlet Spider and
I respect the reach but I am not sure so
it's either Spider-Man or the Scarlet
Spider below them are of course Moon
Knight to the left of those under the
elbow of pug we can't really make out
but we'll move up to the green and
yellow ones with the lightning bolt on
it and there we have Electro above
Elektra we see a brown greenish shoe but
it has little wings on it much like
Namor has on his feet so these are Namor
shoes the ones above Namor are pretty
vague they're just completely yellow but
this could be Power Man Luke Cage I'm
guessing that's what it is the ones
above Luke Cage are very obvious it's
the Hulk but the ones above the Hulk are
kind of hard now we do see a spade on
the shoe which could be Gambit although
these are not Gambit's colors perhaps
he's coming to the MCU and they could be
changing his colors however most of
these other shoes seem to stick to the
correct colors from either the comics or
the Animated Series so I'm not sure
about this one now moving over to the
row on the left we see red and white
shoes these are the OG comic Falcon
colors and as we can see there it does
have the wings that kind of form an F as
well so those are falcons below that are
Nova's shoes we can see the three
different dots there representing the
stars and a Nova project has been
confirmed to be coming to the MCU so
these are most definitely novas now
moving over to the left we have Dr
Strange the blue red and yellow ones and
Below Doctor Strange we have Ghost Rider
we can see the black shoes with the
flames on top and the chain below the
Flames we did get a Donny Blaze and
She-Hulk a play off of Johnny Blaze who
of course is Ghost Rider so perhaps the
true Ghost Rider is coming to the MCU
soon hopefully fingers crossed now at
the next row over at the very top left
the brown and reddish orange shoes could
be the OG Hank Pym Ant-Man suit or they
could be Wong shoes since it is next to
Doctor Strange let me know which one you
think that is in the comments down below
the one below that really hard to make
out can't really tell the shoe but the
one below that right to the left of the
neck of pug these seem to be speed balls
now it's really interesting that they
would throw a speed ball in here but
perhaps speedball could possibly be
coming to the MCU and those are all the
shoes that we can really make out now
like I said there are some really really
cool shoes in here referencing a lot of
really cool Marvel characters the big
question is is this actually hinting
that these characters could be coming
into the MCU I'm inclined to say yes and
here's the reason some of these shoes on
here many of them are for characters who
are already in the MCU like the Hulk
Captain Marvel Moon Knight Vision
America Chavez Hawkeye they're all
already in the MCU then we have Deadpool
we know that Deadpool is making his way
to the MCU along with Nova as well and
of course we know that the thing is
coming with the Fantastic Four so we
have shoes for characters that are
already in the MCU for characters that
we know are confirmed to be coming to
the MCU so it would only make sense that
these other characters are going to be
coming to the MCU as well and that makes
sense in itself because we know the
X-Men are coming to the MCU most likely
in Phase seven but this might be a
little bit of a preview of which X-Men
exactly are coming to the MCU at least
three of them that we can lock down
cable bishop and cyclops and perhaps
that Spade could be for Gambit I do hope
that this is a tease of some future
Heroes that are coming to the MCU if not
it's just kind of a mean tease because
Marvel Studios knows that we dissect
every little thing that they put into
these episodes and also keep in mind
that these sketches that roll during the
credits A lot of them that we've seen
have actually played out in other
episodes we've seen the actual scenes
for them so we might actually end up
seeing the scene where pug and Nikki do
go and buy shoes and if that's the case
hopefully we do get a better look at all
of these shoes that are behind them so
that is the breakdown of the ending of
She-Hulk episode 5 and the credits of
She-Hulk episode 5 a lot of people were
really trying to figure out what these
are I think we nailed most of them but
if you think any are different or you
spotted any that we didn't figure out
let us know in the comments down below
don't forget to like the video please
and of course subscribe to stay up to
date on all the latest news and
breakdowns for live updates you can
follow me on Instagram or Twitter and as
always thank you all so much for
watching woof woof